hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video wie man
hier unschwer erkennen kann mich im
urlaub und weiß dass das mittelmeer
für die die es interessiert auf jeden
fall ist mir so aufgefallen dass ich
schon echt sehr lange kein themen video
mehr gemacht habt und kpd langeweile von
daher habe ich mir dann so gedacht ja
macht mal wieder und ich will eigentlich
auch gar nicht lange lagern und direkt
mal zur sache kommen und ich will
einfach viel spaß
haut rein wir werden immer jünger
ich hab mal ein bisschen im internet
recherchiert und herausgefunden dass es
sehr viele leute gibt die denken ja die
menschheit verblödet einfach total auf
der anderen seite gibt es aber auch
manche die meinen dass er einfach nur
einbildung ich denke da allerdings ein
bisschen anders und ich finde dass man
das so ziemlich von sich selbst abhängig
machen kann ob man jetzt wirklich
verblöden willst du jetzt einfach mal
als beispiel das fernsehen im fernsehen
geht es heutzutage einfach nur noch
darum die leute zu unterhalten und das
spielt überhaupt keine rolle ob die
serie jetzt total sinnlos oder einfach
total respektlos ist es geht einfach nur
noch darum dass so viele menschen wie
möglich einschalten
das auch irgendwie verständlich ist da
die ja irgendwie ihr geld machen wollten
wollen sollen was auch immer und da kann
man jetzt ganz ehrlich für sich alleine
entscheiden ob man diese scheiß serie
die total sinnlos ist unterhaltsam
weiter guckt oder ob man dieses lange
teil namens fernbedienung nimmt und den
fernseher einfach ausmachen
ein weiteres beispiel dafür sind auch
noch talkshows ich meine es sitzen
einfach 10 rappen in einem kreis und
land einfach über ein thema das alle
leute sehen wollen
egal die scheiße oder verblödet es ist
für alle die etwas älter sind und jetzt
dieses video schauen und mein jahr das
mit deutscher stimmt doch gar nicht klar
ich bin 15 dass meine meinung tut mir
leid wenn ihr was zu meckern hat
schreibt einfach unten in die kommentare
sodann geht es auch direkt mal weiter
mit facebook diese neuen facebook seiten
die eigentlich jeder deutsche user
heutzutage oder im moment sage ich mal
gar nicht mehr übersehen kann
mein knie als baustein sie will kopf
lohnen was weiß ich wieder heißt und
seine westlichen kollegen da guckt euch
mal an wann widum seid ihr ohne wird
vielleicht einer von euch wird der kopf
über runter springt aber dann gibt es
immer noch diese personen die einfach
noch einen draufsetzen und das sind
genau die leute die
3000 leicht und ich mach das und das
videos einfach mal zuteil feiern ich
meine ich alleine kann dagegen jetzt
auch nicht wirklich was ausrichten
und eigentlich ist diese person auch
ganz geheilt dann sag ich mal
aber ich bin auch so schlau dass ich
erkenne dass das alles fake ist liga
voll krass ey du hast zwar
runtergeschluckt ich gebe dir erstmal im
krassen like und sucht fällt eher dumm
das ist hält idioten relevant ist so ich
werde jetzt auch so langsam auch hier um
zu labern es hier aus dem stein und das
ist nicht gerade angenehm auf jeden fall
wollte ich euch noch schnell fragen wie
ihr das findet mit der menschheit denkt
ihr wirklich wir verblöden oder seid ihr
anderer meinung schreibt so einfach mal
bitte und in die kommentare
so leute das wasser jetzt auch ehrlich
mit dem video ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen und jelas vielleicht einen
daumen nach oben da wenn es euch
gefallen hat natürlich nur und wenn ihr
nicht mehr verpassen wollt dann
abonniert doch einfach den kanal
ich würde mich freuen und auch auf
anderen netzwerken könnt ihr mir
natürlich folgen oder mit mir freunde
sein je nachdem facebook und instagram
alles und in der video beschreibung und
wir sehen uns dann demnächst irgendwann
mal wieder rein und so
wir werden immer immer schon warm
geworden
ddp